the language police is a new book from
former assistant secretary of education
diane Ravitch she spoke about it
recently at Harvard University for about
an hour on behalf of drew Faust who is
Dean of the Radcliffe Institute of
Advanced Studies and my colleagues here
at the Harvard Graduate School of
Education I am delighted to have the
opportunity to introduce Diane Ravitch
Diane and I were graduate students
together and I won't tell you how long
ago it was but it was quite a long time
ago at Teachers College and we've
remained in touch ever since and one
summer we even rented houses next door
to each other on Martha's Vineyard Diane
is a person of tenacious curiosity her
first book the great school wars grew
out of a fairly straightforward question
Diane had about the new york city public
schools and in pursuit of those fairly
straightforward questions diane not only
wrote a book which after she wrote it
and published it became her dissertation
at columbia she doesn't always do things
in the correct order but in addition to
resulting in a book her question
introduced her to lawrence Cremin who
became her and my mentor currently Diane
is a research professor at the steinhart
school of education at NYU and she also
holds the brown chair in education
policy at the Brookings Institution in
Washington DC she serves on the National
Assessment governing board having served
earlier under the first president Bush
as assistant secretary of education
Diane's tenacious curiosity has led not
only to the great school wars which I
think remains what almost 30 years later
the definitive history of education in
New York City but to many other books
some of them historical and some of them
about education policy and she tells me
she's about to do a book with her son on
English poetry right
Diane has lectured all of the world she
has collected honorary degrees all over
the country and she has accumulated an
innumerable number of honors that i am
not going to bore you with she is going
to talk tonight about her newest book
the language police which as always with
Diane started out with a fairly simple
question and just became quite a saga
Diana well it's great to be here at the
Harvard Graduate School of Education and
I think I drew Faust and especially my
old and dear friend Ellen lagemann as
Ellen mentioned we were graduate
students together but what she didn't
tell you was that I started graduate
school 12 years later than she did so
she is excused from being a member of my
generation oh well I'm here tonight to
at their invitation to speak about the
language police I have to say first of
all I had so much fun writing this book
it's never happened to me before as a
historian to actually wake up in the
morning and be excited about what I was
going to write about because I did
something that I had never done before I
wrote the book in the first person and I
it became for me a detective story and I
have to explain how this came to be I
think that i stumbled across a major
scandal in American education it
involves censorship and speech codes and
big business and state policies that
limit competition and the political
activities of pressure groups that dumb
down textbooks and tests and how this
came about was that in 1997 President
Clinton decided and he announced in his
State of the Union address that he
thought there should be a voluntary
national test in both 4th grade reading
and eighth-grade math and he has signed
the development of this what was called
the VNT the voluntary national test to
the National Assessment governing board
as it happened he appointed me to that
board
and I've joined it in the first meeting
of 1998 and our the board immediately
began reviewing test questions for the
voluntary national test now the
voluntary national test never came to be
because Congress never authorized it
everybody except the public hated the
idea it showed very well in the opinion
polls but Democrats didn't like the idea
Republicans didn't like the idea and it
just didn't go anywhere but I learned
something that to me was incredible I
was on the committee reviewing test
questions test passengers for fourth
graders and we were reading passages
stories that were two and three pages
long that fourth graders would read and
that questions would be based on and our
committee which was composed of I don't
know a dozen or so people educators for
the most part read the passages approve
them and about a year later a bunch of
these passages were returned to us and
we were told that they had to be
eliminated because they had not passed
what was called a bias and sensitivity
review and this was news to me I knew
nothing about bias insensitivity review
but let me tell you some of the stories
that were we were told couldn't be
included and why they couldn't be
included one was the history of peanuts
and it was about George Washington
Carver and the cultivation of the peanut
it seemed like a pretty nice story but
the Bison sensitivity review panel said
that we couldn't include it because some
children are allergic to peanuts and so
that story had to go that children would
be very sensitive they wouldn't be able
to complete the test things like that
then there was a story about the owl and
how the L had a kind of radar that
allowed it to find its prey at night and
they said this story could not be
included because there are some cultures
in this country to whom the owl is taboo
it represents death and therefore L
should never again be represented on
standardized tests so the owl doesn't
exist any more as far as standardized
test makers are concerned a third story
which was a true story was about a young
man who was blind who became the first
blind man
ascend Mount McKinley I point out that
he was not the first blind person to
ascend Mount McKinley because a blind
woman had ascended it before him however
he was the first blind man to ascend
Mount McKinley he did so in an ice storm
and it was a he presented as a rather
heroic tale that accented his courage
the Bison sensitivity reviewers said
this passage could not be used first of
all because it contained regional bias
children who had never been in an ice
storm couldn't possibly understand what
one was and secondly it was offensive to
blind people because it suggested that
it required courage on his part to climb
Mount McKinley in an ice storm and
blindness should not be considered a
handicap for these purposes then there
was a story about it was the 19th it was
a story about women in the 19th century
and how they taught their daughters to
make quilts and it said that quilting
was very important because it became
part of the daughters gallery there were
no commercially produced quilts and so
this was an important mother/daughter
activity in the in the 19th century and
they said this story was gender biased
it showed women is soft and submissive
and had to be eliminated it was a
historically accurate but that was
irrelevant I then there was a story and
it was a short biography of a man named
Gutzon Borglum he was the man who
designed the sculptures are on Mount
Rushmore and it was just a story of his
life and how was a little boy he wanted
to grow up to do monumental sculptures
and he did and the bias insensitivity
reviewers said this story could not be
used because Mount Rushmore was built on
land that was sacred to the Lakota
Indians and it would offend Lakota
children if Mount Rushmore was
represented on a standardized test so
out it went then there was a wonderful
environmental story about how a rotting
stump in the forest is home to many
different kinds of insects and animals
and it becomes they called it the
rotting stump apartment house and and
how this was in a way that nature
recycles for all different kinds of
creatures in the forest and they said
this had to go because it would be
offensive and demeaning to children who
live in housing projects
it seems me that there are a lot of
high-rise apartment buildings that are
really expensive but that that was that
was not relevant and there were many
other stories but just one more that I
mentioned it was a story about mary
mcleod bethune who was an
african-american woman who is a great
educator and it told the story of how
she started a school and Daytona Beach
Florida it was called a Daytona
industrial and training school for Negro
girls and it told her story and they
said this story could not be used for
two reasons actually for more than two
reasons but I only give you two one is
the name of her school which used the
word Negro was offensive and could not
be used and the other was that it said
that she was a tremendous fundraiser she
even managed to get money from john d
rockefeller who was a apparently
wintered in daytona beach and the bison
sensitivity reviewers said we couldn't
use that story because it showed her is
dependent upon John people like john d
rockefeller and other white
industrialists and this was demeaning to
mary mcleod bethune it was true but that
was again irrelevant so I found myself
free puzzled about you know where did
this definition of bias and sensitivity
come from and I realized that while we
were discussing this voluntary national
test for reading and for reading the
publisher of the test who would held a
huge multi-million dollar government
contract had been had given us a set of
guidelines and I went back and I looked
at those guidelines and I thought
everything that just got eliminated was
described in the guidelines that was
described as as biased and to find all
these different kinds of bias the
publisher told us when he met with our
committee to describe what would be in
the reading section of the voluntary
national test that everything written
before nineteen seventy was rife with
either gender bias or racial bias and so
it would be hard to find any pre-1970
passages he gave us in these guidelines
a list of about a 25 page lists of words
and topics and images and stereotypes
that had to be avoided and so what was
considered sensitive would be anything
that it would upset the test taker so
you can't have any reading passages that
deal with catastrophes like for instance
fires or earthquakes you
anything that refers to scary creatures
like rats or mice or lice or roaches I
mean if a child read about a mouse on a
test they would just stop and not be
able to complete the test there should
be nothing about giving birth whether
it's people aren't animals there should
be no reference to ghosts or witches or
goblins are magic there should be no
reference to quarreling parents there
should be no stories about disobedient
children anything that was como tlie
controversial would distract students
and would cause their test scores to be
lower and anything that might make a
student uncomfortable should be
eliminated furthermore anything that
related to race or gender or age or
disability or region or ethnicity or
family was suspect and probably
controversial and should probably be
omitted what the question that I asked
myself as I looked at all of these
passages that had we were told were
biased and as I looked at these
guidelines which seemed I mean some of
them were just alarming you know no
questions about Halloween because
Halloween implies witches and you can't
have anything about witches no questions
about fossils or dinosaurs because they
imply evolution and evolution can't be
brought up well I asked myself how
widespread is this and I began
contacting publishers and publishers of
tests and also publishers of textbooks
and asking them for their guidelines as
some of them quite cheerfully sent me
their bias guidelines which expanded on
the ones that I already had others said
that they didn't have guidelines but I
subsequently found out that they did but
don't like to release them to the public
every publisher has guidelines with long
list of words and topics and stereotypes
and images that you can't see on a test
and that in many cases you will not see
in a textbook state education
departments have them and they're
everywhere so what I did with this with
this book was that I took all the bias
guidelines that I could find and I
didn't find all of them put them all
together collated them and came up with
a list of over 500 words that are banned
today either by test developers or by
textbook publishers I gathered bias
guidelines
from just give you an some the main
contributors McMullen mcgraw-hill scott
foresman addison-wesley ETS American
institutes for research Riverside
publishing which publishes the Iowa Test
of Basic Skills national evaluation
systems which is involved in the MKS
houghton mifflin harcourt and a number
of states including California New York
Connecticut Nebraska Kentucky and also
from Massachusetts as well and I also
collected some from professional
associations some of the words that are
banned and if this is part again of a
list of over 500 words you're not
supposed to say founding fathers you're
supposed to refer to these people
gentlemen guys whatever they are as
founders our framers I sort of thought
the framers were the ones who put my
house up but I don't think so there now
the ones who wrote the Constitution
you're not supposed to say Brotherhood
the word Brotherhood has banned its
ripped to be replaced with Amity so now
we have the Amity of community because
we cannot say the brotherhood of man
that's band also you're not to say
cowboy or cowgirl a year to replace that
with cowhand if that if that subject
ever comes up please remember it's
cowhand lumberjack you're to replace the
term lumberjack with woodcutter I got a
letter from a teenage girl who said I
belong to the lumberjack club in my
school shall we change our our club name
I don't know the word craftsmanship is
banned it's interesting that on this
list of hundreds of words almost all of
them have a replacement or an
alternative suggested by the publisher
but the word craftsmanship there is an
alternative but it's gone the word cult
is gone heretic extremist fanatic Dogma
words like cult heretic extremist
fanatic Dogma or ban because they're
considered ethnocentric words have to
use someone maybe an extremist but to
you but but that person may be an
extremist you but to that the other
person you're an extremist so the word
has to go the word America
or Americans is not to be used to refer
to citizens of the United States for
people who are in the United States
because the word actually is supposed to
represent all people who live in either
North America or South America now if
you take all this too seriously you
cannot use the expression god Bless
America because God is Glenn then
blesses band and so as America so forget
about it you're not to use the
expression Middle East and someone
should please tell the new york times in
the Boston Globe about this you're to
use instead of Middle East you're
supposed to say Southwest Asia so next
we're going to worry about the crisis in
Southwest Asia and you'll know next time
what they're referring to henpecked
husband of course is gone there are no
more henpecked husbands you're not to
say landlord or landlady the year to
replace that with owner words like crazy
or idiot or imbecile or insane or gone
there to be replaced with a person with
the mental disability so next time you
get really angry at your brother or your
spouse your to say you're a person with
a mental disability you're not to use
the term Ombudsman minority group
motherland or fatherland you'll replace
that with native land and one of my
favorites is you're not to say Mother
Russia in case it's ever occurred to you
to say Mother Russia don't do it anymore
instead you're to replace that with
Russia vast land of rich harvest now
some of the topics that test makers have
been from tests or passages about
slavery racial prejudice witches war
social problems animal rights animal
abuse Halloween disobedient children
poverty unemployment offensive expensive
could not offensive expensive consumer
goods so for instance if a child were to
be taking a test and read about some
other trial getting a new bicycle and it
was a really expensive bicycle that
child taking the test would be so upset
and jealous that it would stop them in
their tracks so no more stories about
people living in big homes and like
Great Expectations you should not have
these great differences of wealth and
poverty
so you won't see that anymore now the
other thing that's band is birthday
parties because some children don't have
birthday parties and they would feel bad
and also birthday cake is banned because
that's not a nutritious kind of food
well all of this stuff goes on and I
have to tell you I know from my
experience that I have not found all of
the language codes because I keep
finding funny words in text books and so
I created a website it's called language
police com and i've invited people to
send me bias guidelines that i haven't
seen yet i continued discovered to
discover things that have been banned
since my book was finished the new york
state regents is you probably remember
about a year ago got a lot of national
and even international attention when it
was discovered a vigilant parent
discovered that they had been sanitizing
famous literary passages they were
taking words and phrases out of the
short stories of people like Franz Kafka
and Isaac Bashevis singer there was a
short story of Isaac Bashevis singer
about life in Poland that had to do with
Jews and Gentiles only they removed the
references to Jews and Gentiles so it
was kind of hard to understand the story
once they got done with it there were a
number of other well-known literary
passages that the state had had changed
but they were very embarrassing all the
publicity came out and then the next
round of state testing they did it again
that they took the Matthew Arnold poem
the famous poem Dover Beach and where
the lion says I love let us be true they
changed it to our friend let us be true
now I don't understand why they did that
what's bad about saying I love let us be
true I don't know the National Council
of teachers of English I've discovered
says you're not supposed to use the word
guys you're not supposed to come into
room and say hello guys you can't say
that anymore in Massachusetts as you
probably are all where the reference to
a snow day was considered regional bias
and the test has to be re giving because
some children may not know what a snow
day is because they haven't had
no day that's very much like the stories
that i saw that were banned because a
child can't imagine what it's like to
see an ocean unless they've seen an
ocean and i was talking about this not
so long ago on some talk show where
someone said hey come on you know
supposing a kid hasn't seen a snow day
and I said I grew up in Texas we never
had snow but I knew what snow was it's
not that hard if you read and you assume
that children actually have imaginations
you can believe in the possibility of
snow even if you've never seen it I
learned recently from someone who writes
for textbooks who sent me an email and
said that an excerpt from The Little
House on the Prairie was rejected by the
state of Minnesota because the excerpt
said that the travelers had to circle
the wagon to protect the children and
the animals and the question was why
were they circling the wagons and who
were they protecting them from and this
is an offensive passage to the people
that they were protecting them from so
that passage was out then I the other
day found that my book had been reviewed
in The Scotsman in Scotland and I didn't
want to write to the Scotsman and tell
them that they have to change the name
of their newspaper
but they pointed out in this article
they interviewed a woman in Scotland who
writes for children's books and she had
been selling stories for American
textbook publishers and she said she had
a story in which a child was illustrated
sitting on grandpa's lap and the
American textbook publisher came back
and said you have to change this
illustration it implies incest so she
changed the figure to a child sitting on
grandma's lap which was okay and I
couldn't help to think of an old
expression that I so long ago oh nice
wacky Molly pause evil is he who evil
thinks but then someone from in the
testing business I who will remain
nameless who asked to remain nameless
sent me the guidelines from the state of
Michigan which I hadn't seen Michigan of
course has all the usual subjects that
are not allowed to be touched or
mentioned to understand on its
standardized tests things like dinosaurs
they also had a genetic engineering
which apparently implies evolution but
they added they said you can't have
reference to flying saucers aliens or
extraterrestrials because those things
imply evolution too and I'm still trying
to figure that one out I mean like
what's the flying saucer and aliens and
extraterrestrials got to do with
evolution anyway all of this banning I
mean you could take it all the way back
to the mid 19th century when textbook
adoption first began when the South
wanted to make sure that there were no
unfriendly accounts of the civil war in
their textbooks and they wanted to make
sure that the textbooks referred to the
War of Northern Aggression are rather
than the Civil War but are the most this
most recent a sort of high pitch of
censorship activity began in the 1970s
particularly with feminist who wanted to
eliminate all references to gender they
wanted to eliminate every word that
recognized gender differences everything
that had that three-letter word man
either as a prefix or suffix and with
their success other advocacy groups also
were involved now the sources of
censorship pressures that I have written
about in this book or mainly of toot
they fall into two camps one camp is
called the right wing
and that other campus call the left wing
the right wing wants books and stories
to portray the ideal world of the past
it's a world in which father works
mother takes care of the home and the
children the children are very obedient
it's a world that's free of any social
and economic strife there are no
challenges to biblical Authority there
are no references to divorce or religion
or alcohol or drugs or fantasy there's
no New Age religion there's no secular
humanism no one steals or lies and if
they do they get punished there are no
crimes that are unpunished the right has
managed to kill off reading series by
making them controversial by challenge
challenging them in court are going
before state education boards in Texas
in California and elsewhere and the
basic strategy is and this is true with
any group right left or any of any other
direction if you can make a textbook
controversial you can kill it Holt basic
readers which was part of holt rinehart
and Winston fought off the challenge
from right-wing groups in court and they
won but they lost because their readers
went out of print the right attacks
books like the Harry Potter books and
here's a great paradox the Harry Potter
books happen to me the most popular
books in the United States but they're
also the most banned books in the United
States now why is that two reasons one
harry potter comes from a dysfunctional
family that's a problem but the other
it's probably even more important is
there so much witchcraft and harry
potter so these books are very very
strongly objected to and very frequently
there are many attempts to ban them they
lead the American Library Association
list of banned books now the thing about
the right-wing groups and the
conservative family groups is they
believe in the power of the word they
believe that whatever children we read
will be a role model for them and if
they read something they will do
whatever it is they read about if they
see a child acting disobedient and
disrespecting Authority then their
children to will be disobedient and
disrespect authority the the sensors on
the left also believe in the power
of the word they to believe in the power
of role modeling children should read
only about an ideal gallant Aryan world
and it should be a world as it should be
and not as it is there should be never
any dominant gender erase our nation or
culture and neither age nor disability
should be considered a disadvantage
stereotypes and negative words should be
stamped out and the interest of
diversity all differences should be
eliminated and we should pretend they
don't exist and the irony of this is
that when you look through the list of
the band words and the list of the band
topics and the list of the band
stereotypes doesn't promote diversity we
end up with everyone looking exactly the
same if you look for instance at the
list of stereotypes that you're not
supposed to use and textbooks or on
tests you're not supposed to portray
african-americans as great athletes or
as great entertainers and you're not
supposed to portray Asian Americans as
great students are as having strong
family values you're not supposed to
portray Jews as professors or doctors
the lawyers you're not supposed to
portray old people as sickly or feeble
or needing a cane or a walker well what
can you do with old people it's really
good to show people who are older
jogging that's a very important thing
that we do I'm of that age now where i
can say that most of the time i like to
go up on my roof and repair it that's my
favorite activity and you can't show you
can't show reality you can't show people
that reflect society today because there
is a sphere of stereotyping well given
the nature of state textbook adoptions
it's very easy to intimidate publishers
what publishers textbook publishers are
most fearful of is controversy because
that's what will kill their series even
if like the whole company they win the
lawsuit they lose the the book so the
deal that has come out of the
controversies of the last 20 years at
least as I've seen it is the right wing
gets to censor topics and the left wing
gets to censor words and images it's the
neat deal everybody gets to censor
everything so when you look at the
textbook adoption
as I have done you see that 22 states
adopt textbooks for the whole state and
the big to our California and Texas and
over these past 25 or so years the
pressure groups of all sorts from the
right from the left and from different
advocacy groups have gained power by
coming to the hearings and threatening
to make books controversial and the
publishers have so much at stake that
they capitulate rather than risk
becoming controversial or being rejected
and largely because of this system of
state textbook adoption there are today
only for mega corporations for
conglomerates dominating about 70 to 75
percent of a four billion dollar
educational publishing industry at the
time I was writing my book it was
mcgraw-hill Reed Elsevier pearson and
vivendi since then vivendi has been sold
off its houghton mifflin unit I haven't
followed who bought it because it wasn't
really relevant but the relevant point
was massive concentration with each of
these companies owning multiple textbook
companies and testing companies well in
order to dig into these questions I
wanted to find out from publishers what
their experience had been and I
contacted people I knew in the
publishing industry and they were very
nice and took me to lunch and said of
course we're not going to let you see
our files do you think we're crazy you
know where we're private companies we're
not going to open our books up to you
you're just in whatever you say well
embarrasses well there were there were
two companies where I was fortunate
enough to be able to see their files one
was the whole files as I mentioned
earlier there was a Supreme Court case
in the 1980s involving the hope basic
readers and so the whole files over
2,000 pages were subpoenaed and this was
the internal correspondence amongst the
editors and these files were part of the
discovery process and so I was able to
get a copy of them and their make its
extraordinary reading a halt was
whipsawed between the right and the left
and the 1980s as they were constantly
pressed by feminists to have gender
equality the issue of gender
representation became more important
than literary
quality one letter from the editor of
the series said he was reviewing new
stories trying to increase the number of
girls in the book and in the books
because it was a series not just one
book and he said well this story gets a
plus because it has two girls it has a
Latina the quality of the story is for
added in the published stories of the
holt readers as they were revised the
gender and the ethnicity of the
characters were changed almost at will
to meet this goal of 50 50 that was
required by both California and then by
Texas in one story a character was
changed from mrs. J to mrs. Chang in
order to insert an Asian character and
another story call Freddy in the middle
Freddie became Maggie in the middle it
was just a gender change very easy easy
and then in another story a grandmother
who was totally irrelevant to the story
was inserted in order to get an older
person in well when Holt got to the
Texas hearings having satisfied
California they got to the Texas
hearings and feminists complained that a
one-to-one representation of male-female
was not good enough because they had not
counted the animals in the stories and
they said that mr. rabbit was just as
influential to a girls self-esteem as
any other male character well the whole
files were fascinating I put them I have
stored stashed them in a place where
they're open to the public at the end
the Hoover files on hoover institution
has archives and i put them in the
hoover archives another set of files
came from open court and the reason I
was able to get the open court files was
that open court was sold around nineteen
ninety it would used to be an
independent company and in the great
consolidation era it was sold to
macmillan mcgraw-hill so it's now the
original company's files were available
to me I contacted the bloke Charis who
sent me the files and what I found
reading through all of his
correspondence about these issues was
that open court was getting excellent
results on teaching reading the open
court series started out with an
intention it was in the mid-60s that it
began their intention was to teach
traditional myths and folktales and
legends
they were very quickly under attack by
feminist groups as soon as they started
because of a lack of gender balance in
California rejected open court for their
lack of gender balance and for their
old-fashioned content the state was
literally saying to them you have too
many folktales too many myths too many
legends get up to date and have these
relevant modern stories well among the
things that open court did in order to
try to meet the California requirements
and get adopted was that they changed
the little engine that could from a male
to a female so that made California feel
better they were also told by the state
that Mother Hubbard was a sexist figure
and they should get rid of her but you
know again what you find is that these
the stereotype issue is one that was
very tough for open court to deal with
because they were trying to teach Greek
myths Roman myths myths of other
cultures and there are stereotypes but
they sold a company and now there are no
more stereotypes in the open court
readers I looked at literature text
books and suffice is say I have a
chapter about them I found them terribly
disappointing because literature
textbooks today have a tremendous visual
clutter they look they try to look like
web pages very distracting they're
incoherent there is no effort to teach
literary tradition anything that's
printed these days is considered
literature and I will not dwell on that
because I want to talk a minute or two
about the history textbooks I have a
chapter in the history textbooks and
again history textbooks have always been
controversial I as I'm the subtitle of
my chapter is the endless battle this is
nothing new this story of fighting over
history textbooks the world history
textbooks following the California
guidelines which say that everybody has
to be treated nicely really not you
can't catch you it the way they put it
is no negative aspersion or no adverse
aspersion on anyone no adverse treatment
and so the world history texts bend over
backwards to treat all cultures as being
equivalent all cultures are great and
glorious there are no invidious
comparisons no culture is more or less
advanced than any other culture slavery
seems to be a European invent
when slavery occurs in the Middle East
or Africa it is portrayed as a means of
social mobility as a means of gaining
higher status it is a benign portrayal
the text cannot bring themselves to say
anything critical of any religion and
consequently they tell religious origin
stories is if they were history this is
one of the worst things about world
history textbooks today particularly the
middle grades schools you will see the
origins fables and myths treated as if
these are documented stories and then
when it when the world history texts
come around to dealing with regimes that
are today still in power they become
tongue-tied so for instance when they
deal with Ayatollah Khomeini the story
they tell is that there was a corrupt
and repressive Shah and the story
usually just ends there you know there
was a revolution the Shah was thrown out
and he was replaced by people who wanted
to have a strong religious tradition
they do not mention the executions that
took place under the ho mania regime
they do not mention the fought was or
Salman Rushdie or anything of that kind
when that when the textbooks deal with
mouths a tongue he comes across as a
friendly inclusive leader who listened
to the peasants he cut taxes he reduced
inflation he built roads and schools and
bridges and hospitals he also killed
millions of people but there were some
bad policies he was a reformer in a
hurry now what is troublesome about the
world history textbooks is that with one
notable exception they all have advisory
committees made up of representatives of
ethnic and religious groups which tell
the publisher is what to include and
what to leave out pertaining to their
own group you cannot have honest
critical history with this kind of
vetting by advocacy groups so what I
found an answer to the quest that I
embarked upon was I think a very
alarming story it's a story about
widespread censorship which is now
treated by state education apartments
and by the testing industry and by the
textbook industry as quote the industry
standard the second I was what I was
alarmed by was the extent to
which these practices are hidden from
public view third by the dumbing down
and the falsification that it causes in
textbooks and on tests and I ask myself
as I looked through all of this material
how can we possibly transmit any sense
of a culture of a multi culture of all
that we are as a people and all that
other peoples in the worlds are I how
can we promote critical thinking when
there is so much sanitizing so much
bowdlerized and so much censorship
behind the scenes so my suggestions for
ending the censorship and it's not going
to happen quickly but I believe it can
happen first I think we need an informed
public I think there should be a level
of public outrage about all of the
censorship secondly I would urge that we
stop state textbook adoptions this is a
little bit like closing the barn door
after the horses out of it and I'm not
sure if I just said something that's
against a guideline there but I do think
that if we stop state adoptions it would
help to break up the quasi monopoly that
we now have with for mega corporations
dominating the textbook industry I
believe this is where the pressure
groups get their power to harass
publishers and to impose the revisions
for political reasons I know that it
still goes on because I have all of the
the complaints and responses from
publishers from the last Texas State
adoptions the stack of papers is two and
a half feet high so it goes on secondly
was with the stopping of state adoptions
I would hope that we could create and
encourage competition for the purchase
of school materials we should have a
real market place instead of a
government procurement system where
publishers expect to sell their products
their books to millions of teachers
instead of to a small number of school
boards with a real market and with
millions of book buyers there would be a
market for textbook review there's
virtually no textbook reviewing today
because the decisions are made by so few
people and third i would say let
teachers choose the books they want to
use and I've had people say to me well
you can't have those teachers choosing
those books there are three million of
them many many of them don't know their
subject they're teaching out of field
and my senses I would rather trust three
million teachers
than to state school boards next I would
say we should not end bison sensitivity
reviewing of testing but I believe that
it should be made public there should be
transparency the those who write these
bias guidelines and who implement them
should be required to tell the public on
their website whether their state
education department or a test publisher
what the guidelines are what words and
topics are van who sits on these panels
what was deleted what text they used and
what they censored before they gave it
to the students and last I would say and
I think it's appropriate to say it in
these halls we need better educated
teachers who know how to choose
wonderful literature and good history
books not just text books but novels and
biographies and poetry anthologies I
don't believe that we should tolerate
this language police I don't think we
should tolerate this kind of censorship
we don't need speech codes we don't need
all of these banned words and banned
topics we don't need people who tell us
what we should read what we should think
and what we should say I for one and it
may be controversial to say if i'll say
that anyhow I've done this for I want to
be free to speak about the founding
fathers and about the brotherhood of man
and if somebody else doesn't want to
then they shouldn't do it I want to
laugh when Rex Harrison sings in my fair
lady why can't a woman be more like a
man you know I think it's funny I would
I don't want to see it banned enough of
the regime of thought control let's end
it we don't need it there's no place for
a language control in a free society
thank
we ask when you ask questions to please
wait for the microphone to be brought to
you for us people watching won't have
any idea with questions pittsville
process sounds terribly inefficient and
Honduras and I'm wondering if anybody's
estimated how much extra it's costing
school districts to purchase texts to
pay for all this stuff because our
ultimate lee the consumer will be the
the Board of Education that's buying the
books well the short answer is I have no
idea what it costs but I do know that
every state education appointment has
this kind of a bison sensitivity review
the federal government does all the
tests publishers do and frequently
materials are subject to more than one
sometimes two sometimes three at each
level that they're used their reviewed
yet again so it's a filtering down I
have no idea of estimating the cost I'm
sure though that it's not in substantial
okay see um it's this one yeah this is
mr. Smith all right um is there anybody
it sounds like the problems you're
describing sounds like a sort of
straightjacket an education is there
anybody that's operating outside the
straightjacket any independent
publishers they'd get their books to the
schools or is it only these four major
publishers well I said that they do from
what I've read in education week in the
Wall Street Journal these four major
their conglomerates because some of them
on multiple publishing houses they
control about somewhere to seventy
seventy-five percent of the market there
are there are others who are in that
niche of twenty-five to thirty percent I
have time it again encountered schools
and teachers where the teachers are not
using textbooks or if they use them
they're just a reference work there are
a few good textbooks I'm not damning all
textbooks but I am always inspired when
I hear of teachers who assign the whole
novel the whole play and make sure that
they they're buying a novel or a play
that has not been bolder eyes me one of
the amazing things I discovered was if
you read the Kota to Ray Bradbury's
Fahrenheit 451 he this is a book
bad book about book burning it's a novel
about book burning he said that he got
many letters from students at one point
years ago saying to him do you realize
that there are passages that have been
cut out of Fahrenheit 451 and he went
back and he checked what was being sold
against what he wrote and he found 75
deleted passages and he went ballistic
and I quoted his reaction to this but he
said he changed publishers and made sure
that everything was restored so part of
the problem here is it's not just
textbooks but very often the mass-market
books that are sold to schools have been
sanitized as Shakespeare's frequently
sanitized other others have discovered
that there are three hundred lines that
are usually cut out of Romeo and Juliet
because they they're too sexy I mean the
idea of our kids being concerned about
sex and Shakespeare is beyond my
imagination I have a question about what
the current climate in terms of
accountability foretells for testing
because there is increased pressure now
on states and localities to use tests it
so what what are your comments or
thoughts I don't think that increased
accountability has to mean increase
censorship what I what I learned was
that this whole Enterprises has been
carried on in the dark for many many
years even when there was very little
accountability the censorship was
becoming systematized so it's not a
result of an increased pressure for
testing it's a result of all of those
other pressures you know the censorship
groups old finding how easy it was to
intimidate publishers in state education
boards but I would hope that the
increased accountability will give
increased visibility to this process of
censorship and my fear is that state
education departments will simply avoid
using classic literature for the same
reason that I was told by the head of
Riverside publishing that everything
written before nineteen seventy
contained bias I think that you know I
hate bias it's awful kids have to learn
to grapple with it they grapple with it
on television they
apple with it the movies they see it and
then when you come to school and see
that everything is somehow sweet and
nice it to me it has two effects one is
that it generates boredom and the other
is it generates cynicism because they
know that the world is not sweet and
nice and when there is bias they have to
learn how to confront it and deal with
it and defuse it my question a couple
who owns how would you describe the
owners of these book companies to what
do you think the effect of rap or
hip-hop language might have in terms of
learning and lastly I feel blessed that
my child has an african-american social
studies teacher who makes sure there's
no sanitization both in the selection of
the book as well as his update and for
us I think that is the answer people who
are well informed and well in touch with
the subject even from a personal
experience as well as in other words you
don't I don't try to teach you your
history when you know your history
better than I do the first question you
asked me was who owns these big
corporations their public corporations
and this is also another reason being
well whether they were public or private
you know they're owned by stockholders
and they don't want controversy it's the
nature of the textbook business that
controversy kills your product it's an
interesting difference between general
publishing like this is my books
published by Knopf if I can create huge
controversies I'll fill more books in
the textbook business if you get a huge
controversy your book is dead so that's
what that's the stranglehold that the
censorship groups have can you wait just
a minute
you're just talking to that one extra
huh I am curious since I think not only
for me but for most of the people in the
room the mmm the efforts to censor are
so ludicrous they're so patently how
shall I say silly that I wonder what has
been the reaction to your publication
now the book is is new but you will
surely published shorter pieces
elsewhere and so on how are people
responding to this kind of thing aren't
they ashamed well you know the only
thing I can gauge it by is the response
of a year ago when there was a front
page story in The New York Times saying
that the Regents exams had been
sanitizing important literature and
there was the the general response let's
say from the public was ridiculed and so
the State Education Department as I said
said we won't do it anymore but they're
still doing it a little bit only they're
doing a little bit now and I think
basically what they're doing is not
using passages that need to be sanitized
which is in a way scary because it means
that there'll be it's a different level
of censorship the response to my book
has been extraordinary you know as an
author I must say this I've always done
somewhat scholarly books and this is a
different level of response you know
fortunately writers respond then writers
hate censorship and so the reviews have
been superb how do textbook publishers
respond I haven't heard from them yet
but I am getting as I said I'm getting
emails from people who work in the
textbook industry and who work in the
testing industry saying I've been doing
this for years and I am so glad that you
brought this out to the public because I
couldn't do it and people have been
sending me more and more examples of
censorship that they that they know of i
was sent the other day someone in the
testing industry sent me a number of
stories that had been eliminated during
the bias review and one of them was a
long poem by not not a famous author but
a contemporary author and it had the
heard prayer in it it wasn't about
praying just had the word prayer and so
the whole thing was thrown out but there
were a number of stories of you know
similar kinds of thing a word a phrase
the whole thing had to go it's very
silly and that's why I think the light
of day it would be such a curative here
because with most of these things the
publishers like I had the experience
with several of the major publishers
right I wrote and said can I see your
bias guidelines and they said oh we
don't do that in fact in the this area
and the Boston Herald there was a story
about my book and so the reporter went
to a representative from hard court and
they said oh we don't censor anything we
use bias insensitivity review and we
make sure not to censor well that's
exactly what they're doing is applying
these guidelines and I saw the hardcore
hardcore guidelines and they they look
just like everyone else's guidelines
eliminate these words these topics these
phrases these images what I wanted to
ask you some of the practices by
publishers sound illegal for example
under intellectual property laws Oh
plagiarism or even freedom of speech who
use the publisher permission to remove
words from Kafka's story which has
royalty somebody has rights to the to
that property intellectual property how
do they get over that cannot be used but
to prevent this happening well that's a
very good question and it probably it
would not be a problem with Kafka
because Kafka is no longer copyrighted
but the new york state education
apartment on the Regents exams did
literally change words in copyrighted
material without asking the author there
were a number of contemporary writers
one is ernesto I forget assessing i
mispronounced it Gallardo I think it was
the story called barrio boy and he used
words like he referred to a woman as a
gringo and they said gringo was not
acceptable so they changed the word
gringo to American lady and then he
referred to another student as fat and
they changed that word too heavy I mean
they were just at will going through
someone's copyrighted literature a short
story and changing words because they
thought someone would
you would find it offensive to be
referred to as heavy or fat so yes
you're right i think there is a legal
issue and i but i would imagine that the
only one who could bring that kind of
action would be the author themselves
you said near the end of your talk that
you would not entirely eliminate di FF
analysis and bias analysis from testing
as opposed to text books what role do
you think there is for some limited
amount of review of that kind of
material and how would you have it
implemented so that it doesn't mushroom
into the monstrosity that you've
described here that that's a very good
question and you bring up the diff
analysis and diff is differential item
functioning and and the idea is that you
could identify items that operate
differently on a test for one group as
against another group and that's a whole
big discussion which I deal with very
briefly in my book the research on the
effects of sensitivity analysis is very
slender as far as I could tell I am
still looking for any research that will
prove to me that if a student sees a
story about about a rat or a mouse that
the student won't be able to function on
and do the test I I guess I could be
persuaded if there were research but
I've never seen the research as far as
the diff analysis goes which says this
question functions better for boys that
it does for girls so remove everything
having to do with the military because
girls can it girls don't know anything
about the military they can't answer
those questions I believe that these
views about military and sports had to
do with a different era women are in the
military women play sports it's a whole
new world but all of these assumptions
were locked into place 25 years ago so I
suspect that the other thing that I
learned is that when when the diff
analysis is supplied it doesn't affect
test scores anyway it's such a tiny
percent of questions where there is any
of this kind of difference shown that
boys will do better on about military
questions and girls and I really do
think that boys and girls should be able
to answer the same kinds of questions
and if they don't then it doesn't seem
to make that much difference in terms
their test scores but what I would
really think is terribly important is
the idea of transparency of continue the
Bison sensitivity review but make it
public put it out there so that everyone
reporters researchers the public can say
what words you banning what what lingo
is considered inappropriate on a test
and if it's ridiculous than opening up
to ridicule if it's serious then it then
you know take the words out but it but
make your case hi I don't know if I have
a question but I have a thought I'd like
to see what you think about it yeah I'm
listening to all of this and you know it
just seems to me like textbooks aren't
the way to go and as I'm listening to
talk you've made a couple comments about
how you know what the good teacher does
I'm a school psychologist I see all
types of teachers and you know so if if
we're sitting here in this seat and
we're you know listening to you or you
know go so far to actually buy the book
then do we really want something to
change and if we do then who are we
going to try to impact are we going to
try to impact the principal or the local
you know school board who it's pretty
hard to impact but if we're at least
just trying to establish how should it
be done which is why I came to this talk
rather than go swimming it seems to me
that the textbook is just crap anyway
the whole idea of it is is is a failure
and that if you really do have a good
teacher they aren't going to be relying
on this textbook very much at all in
fact the textbook is almost a burden and
if you think about what happens here at
the school of ed it which I haven't been
to in years but anyway when I was here
there were a couple of textbooks but
mainly you know the really hot teachers
had readings and and this kind of thing
so well I think that you know what your
thought is a good thought and I'm glad
you came here instead of going swimming
you can still go swimming later yeah but
I it I would suggest that people who
teach literature should use literature
and they should they should help
children develop standards of judgment
as to what is really wonderful poetry
what I didn't like about the literature
textbooks that I just thought was awful
is they don't make any effort to say
this is what good writing looks like
because they include so much bad writing
and so they don't they don't really
encourage a sense of standards about
this this is a wonderful way to use the
language that we have instead there was
11 literature textbook had part of a
script from Xena Warrior Princess not
great literature and they're just
overburdened with all sorts of social
studies articles and science articles
and issue articles and how to review and
how to preview and how to it's like they
took all the teachers instructions and
put them into the student book so I
would say if I would hope literature
teachers would look for the best plays
the best novels the best poetry and give
their students a sense of what best is
the things that would move them to
excitement to tears to a sense of I love
this and I want to read it again at that
kind of feeling I didn't see that in the
literature textbooks the history
textbook struck me is probably the worst
way to learn history because so much of
it has been just boiled down to choppy
sentences disconnected one thing after
another and it's gosh you know there's
so many wonderful histories written for
young people written for students of
different ages and wonderful biographies
that I think good teachers will I would
hope would select from real writing by
one writer I mean I one of the same
ideas I had was maybe teachers should
use two different textbooks so that
students understand that not everyone
agrees I mean to me that was the biggest
thing that I hated in the history
textbooks was the sense of your now
hearing the voice of disembodied
authority this is like reading an
encyclopedia this is truth well it's not
truth everything that they did they say
in the history
books is highly contested but you don't
have the sense of the contest you don't
have the debate you don't have the
argument you just get a lot of dead
facts that have been strung together so
yes I think there is a message here well
I haven't studied other country so I
can't say but I did recently read on the
internet a study from a professor
somewhere in England who said that
history is being rewritten to make it
nicer and he said that it used to be
that we taught that the Vikings raped
and pillaged now we described the
Vikings as agents of cultural exchange
and it's funny because I got an email
from someone who heard this and he said
he said I'm a member of the Society of
Creative Anachronism I'm a descendant of
the Vikings and I can assure you we were
not only agents of cultural exchange we
also raped and pillaged the language
police how pressure groups restrict what
students learn is published by konov a
division of Random House visit Random
House calm / konov to get more
information